[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour
cette nouvelle saison de dimanche en
politique
heureux de vous retrouver une année qui
va être marqué par l'événement
incontournable des élections municipales
c'est notre thème du jour
que va-t-il se passer les 15 et 22 mars
prochains le scénario les gagnants les
perdants les thèmes de campagne on va en
débattre avec patrice josette en pièce
de zabou jours bonjour vous êtes le
référent la république en marche dans
l'yonne et des municipales parte fort
chez vous en particulier du côté de sens
on va en parler pendant cette émission
catherine hervieu bonjour bonjour
conseillère municipale europe ecologie
les verts et que vous êtes la présidente
de la fève la fédération des élus verts
et écologistes tout à fait océane marie
godard bonjour bonjour conseiller
régional vice présidente du conseil
régional et par ailleurs secrétaire
national et par ailleurs conseillère
municipale à 10 ans concernent pas des
gens et secrétaire national s'était fait
au parti socialiste
ludovic rochette bonjour vous êtes le
président des maires de côte-d'or
conseiller départemental et l'air et
vous-même maire de brognon en côte d'or
alors on s'y habitue depuis plusieurs
décennies c'est une tradition en france
à chaque élection de mi-mandat général
concentre sur le pouvoir en place
sauf que le pouvoir en place n'est pas
en place dans les mairies
cette fois il ya très peu de maires la
république en marche donc de vie
crochète il va rien se passer dans cette
élection
ainsi en côte d'or il va se passer les
maires sortants vont garder leur siège
il va voir 698 tu fais et la question
c'est de savoir où le curseur à se
placer entre un dégagisme qu'on pourrait
sentir qu'on a senti l année dernière à
légitimisme du à l'élection moi je suis
convaincu que ce serait une élection
avec la plus grande proximité tels qu'on
n'a pas vu les coups de barres ça serait
vraiment une très grosse surprise c'est
d'ailleurs je pense qu attendent
beaucoup des habitants
le retour au local océane scharre et
godard le ps n'est pas dans une forme
olympique
est ce que ça peut handicaper les maires
socialistes ou est ce que finalement
comme ils sont pas au pouvoir ils sont
pas aux affaires
ils vont pas être sanctionner les maires
socialistes sont aux affaires dans l'eau
dans leur ville ils sont aux affaires et
ça fonctionne
moi je voudrais juste souvient du vote
sanction qu'il y avait eu la hollande
pour cette petite musique de fond vote
sanction dégagisme les parties sont tous
les mêmes droite gauche c'est pareil non
c'est pas pareil en marche
l r oui c'est pareil ça je peux
l'entendre cette petite musique pourquoi
elle est dangereuse en fait elle est
dangereuse parce que je crois qu'il est
parti incarne la démocratie et si on
continue avec cette petite musique en
fait ça appauvrit le débat d'idées c'est
ça devient le règne finalement de la
politique spectacle et ça devient une
démocratie aux médias médiatique
sondagière comme on peut le voir avec en
marche aujourd'hui donc très
sérieusement arrêtons avec ces a priori
et regardons l'état de la politique en
france aujourd'hui il ya un bloc
d'extrême droite
trente pour cent il ya un bloc de droite
dont le président emmanuel macron 30%
il ya un bloc de gauche qui représente
également 30%
certes on apparaît divisé sur des
élections nationales mais sur du local
on est rassemblée enfin regarder à dijon
nous sommes collègues avec catherine
hervieu depuis 2001 françois rebsamen
fait un travail et incarne la social
démocratie dans les projets hier nous
étions à la piscine du cas actuellement
vous êtes dans le bloc de droite donc
l'hygiène à prendre là je suis très
surpris d'être associés à l'ère
notamment quand je prends la vue le sens
on a une maire sortante ait l'air et il
ne semble pas que quel soit avec nous
j'ai cru comprendre que quelques restes
et l'air et qu'elle aurait une candidate
soutenue par la reine en face d'elle
c'est un enjeu fort les municipales pour
vous parce que vous avez pas d'élus
locaux il fait d'autres partis
n'existera que si la démission d'un
enjeu extrêmement important c'est l'acte
2 de notre mouvement comme le rappelait
stanislas guérini est donc l'objectif
c'est de passer s'était déclaré en
conférence de presse ou de tout début du
premier investiture de passer de 2000 à
10 mille élus locaux un cetc
c'est quelque chose de raisonnable de
raisonner aidé atteignable et donc on si
j'ose dire on y va low profile on se
donne aux se donne les moyens de réussir
avec elle on va y revenir parce qu'on va
parler des stratégies mais puisque
puisque vous vous dites maintenant avec
quelle stratégie
vous faites partie de la droite où vous
allez allez vous vous alliez avec des
maires de gauche aux alliés des
opposants de droite ex opposant de
gauche que l'ambiguïté c'est assez
pratique en fait comme dit garder à
marseille à marseille et l'as raismes
prévoit de faire une liste mais à
condition qu'ils s'allient à gaudin
visiblement ça fait pas rêver et c'est
parce qu'il est son champ d'eau on voit
bien qu'il ya aussi des gars aussi dans
l'yonne un maire un ancien maire
socialiste différait ce qui envoie des
signes à la république en marche dans
mon coeur vous et tous des la stratégie
c'est d'abord d'investir de soutenir les
maires qui se font un bon job il s'agit
pas de dégager quelqu'un nous le dégager
c'est pas notre truc on et bienveillance
et l'adn on ne dégage pas donc s'il ya
un maire qui a fait un bon job qui à nos
valeurs républicaines se humaniste et
progressiste qu'elle pour quelle raison
on dit alpes avec lui donc il ya aucune
raison de parler d'une stratégie à
géométrie variable simplement qu'on
essaye de trouver la personne qui sera
la plus à même de gagner une élection
est aussi des proches de ce citoyen
compétentes avec de l' expertise très
nerveux
ensemble après quand même ce que je
viens d'entendre pour le coup là on
entendait dont il a déjà refait la
majorité n'ont elles pas je dis d'abord
n'est pas fait c'est en arrêtant la
question mais vous avez un ils sont
intervenus tous les trois j'ai entendu
des histoires d'appareils d'étiquettes
il y aura peut-être y aura une
différence sans doute entre les communes
rurales et les grosses villes par
rapport à l'affichage politique nous la
question tant qu'écologistes et comment
les citoyens vont s'approprier cette
élection par rapport aux enjeux du
climat aux enjeux de la biodiversité et
par rapport à la façon aussi dont chacun
s'y retrouve puisque on a vu l'année
dernière l'émergence de gilet jaune sur
la question de la fiscalité carbone qui
a été très très mal conduite par le
gouvernement la question de la
redistribution et des moyens pour faire
la transition écologique clairement elle
va se poser dans les territoires elle se
pose déjà il y à des collectivités qui
ont engagé cette transition
pour l'instant ça ne va pas assez vite
et ça ça va être l'enjeu des prochaines
municipales il ya un point stratégique
qui était nouveau quand même pour vous
c'est ce qu'a dit yannick jadot on va
choisir on va regarder on n'est pas voué
à être la question du projet c'est la
question du projet qu'est ce qu'on est
dans le temps dans dans le contenu dans
la feuille de route pour les six ans qui
viennent en sachant que le giec à
l'échelle mondiale alerte alerte alerte
les climato-sceptiques commence à être
un petit peu mis sur la touche mais ça
ne suffit pas et on voit bien
l'émergence dans la société avec des
listes ou en tout cas des déformations
écologique et citoyenne qui commence à
prendre forme dans beaucoup de
collectivités de mais enfin dans
beaucoup de villes dans beaucoup de
communes et cette aspiration là il fait
valoir aussi que les candidats les
leaders en tiennent compte
sous une forme vous lirez suis pas
spécialiste de la petite de marseille
comme henri godard en côte-d'or en tout
cas
ce qu'on fait dans les départs dans les
communes ce qu'on essaie de faire au
département ce qui se fait d'ailleurs
dans la région de xavier bertrand
c'est entre deux digues l'extrême gauche
extrême droite de savoir si on peut
trouver une entente entre des femmes des
hommes qui ont envie de porter un projet
commun et c'est là où je crois moi
vraiment un but politique enfin plus de
politiques de partis donc ou mal je
crois c'est le grand d étiquetage des
municipales qui commence lorsque l on va
se le dire juste on sait très bien que
les élections municipales c'est le
moment où d'un coup les étiquettes de
partis disparaissent des affiches juste
juste juste pour finir les sites et des
étiquettes
effectivement elles disparaissent m
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui aux actions
municipales ouvrent un mais comme vous
rangez votre localisation on peut penser
qu'elles vont disparaître encore plus
oui parce que moi je crois je crois pas
en fin de compte aux ruissellements je
crois d'autant plus aujourd'hui à la
capitation en fait qu est ce qui se fait
dans dans les communes j'espère qu'on
sera capable de le faire à plus grande
échelle
effectivement on a chacun des
sensibilités mais quand on parle du
cadre de vie c'est pas qu'un de rugby de
gauche ou de droite ou de centre
on est on veut avoir un avenir que l'on
souhaite fonder façonner ensemble je
souriais je souriais parce que vous
parler d'étiquettes deux parties pardon
mais vous êtes comptable aussi de la
politique du département
quand vous arrêtez de manière arbitraire
une subvention pour l'opéra de 50000
euros pour la vapeur qui est une scène
de musiques actuelles à dijon de 50000
euros
sous prétexte que celle bénéficierait
cody jaune et ce qui est complètement
faux puisqu'il n'y a plus de 15 %
d'habitants de côte-d'or qui viennent et
ses infrastructures et c'est cette
culture cette accession à culture ça
bénéficie à tous les habitants
pardonnez moi mais là c'est de la
politique politicienne que vous faite
puisque on a l'impression de dijon ne
fait pas partie de la côte d'or alors
c'est peut-être un scoop vous l'heureux
l'airé au président du département dijon
les dijonnais sont côte-d'oriens donc
doivent aussi bénéficier des subventions
du département
c'est pas votre c'est pas votre point de
vue donc on voit bien la ligne de
fracture vous souhaitez vous souhaitez
vous une élection municipale qu'ils
soient politiques clairement dans ce
métier je ne sais pas ça la politique
non pas du tout
une question s'était pas c'est un
jugement de valeur vous voulez réagir
oui la politique des municipales sais
c'est pas une question d'appareils je
suis d'accord avec mon collègue et l'air
alors on va peut-être crois que comme
nous sommes des alliés mais c'est
vraiment une question d'hommes et de
femmes parce qu'elles sont compétents et
se soucier la stratégie de nicolas
sarkozy
sauf que si nicolas sarkozy des maires
de droite ça a été la saint barthélémy
où françois hollande à gauche ça a été à
nouveau la saint-barthélemy vos
meilleurs projets pour leur vision des
faits regardez ce qui se fait surnommer
ben justement part je comptais regarder
ce qui se fait aussi dans des petites
communes je pense à lure en haute-saône
je pense à joigny dans l'yonne je pense
au creusot ont parlé du creusot tout à
l'heure je pense à dijon évidemment
enfin là on parle de faits donc je veux
bien que vous fassiez le procès d'être
dans de la police policière regardons
les faits regardez-moi je vous annonce
que je prolonge votre remarque en
rappelant qu aux européennes par exemple
l'exemple d'une ville comme dijon la
république en marche c'est un très gros
score par rapport au parti socialiste
donc ça veut dire que les gens viennent
pas forcément valider une vision
socialiste dans les 81 82% des dijonnais
sont contents de ce qui est fait donc
six il faut en parler dégagisme s'il
faut dégager des gens qui font le boulot
qu'ils sont investis qui porte un projet
et puis c'est pas porter un projet
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière c'est du ces
de la qualité de vie c'est le quotidien
des personnes et s'est pas donné ses 82
% sont satisfaits on se demande pourquoi
ils ont voté en masse pour la république
en marche aux européennes oui on parle
des élections municipales mais avec le
rôle des intercommunalités
c'est la question les intercommunalités
qui ont de plus en plus les compétences
structurantes encore elle assure encore
insisté sur le climat structurantes
justement pour les questions climatiques
et environnementales et biodiversité
c'est la question des mobilités c'est la
question du développement économique en
lien avec la région certes c'est la
question de l'urbanisme de comment on
continue à faire du logement mais du
logement de qualité
avec on évite les passoires thermiques
et comment comment chacun d'entre nous
impliquer dans la vie citoyenne et
démocratique
on va porter pendant les campagnes
municipales le projet de territoire de
l'intercommunalité puisque moi je me
souviens en 2014
aucun aucun candidat et même celui dijon
aucun candidat n'avait affiché une
vision intercommunale une vision à
d'agglomération et tous espèrent cette
fois c'est une vraie question
démocratique et nous les écologistes est
en tout cas au niveau de quand on avait
des parlementaires et au niveau de la
fédération des élus verts et écologistes
on a on soutient on a toujours mis en
avant et la nécessité d'avoir des
élections directes au niveau de
l'intercommunalité et ça ne s'est pas
fait par les associations la question
elle reste mais moi ces cadres étaient
montés sans un peu à l'opposé qui
semblent importantes est-ce qu'il faudra
être écologiste pour garder son siège de
maire ou pour être élu maire à cette
élection
on pose la question parce que tout le
monde est en train de le devenir à la
vitesse grand v donc effectivement
simplement compris que les temps ont
changé que les collectivités ou un rôle
considérable comme vous l'avez rappelé
les communes et les intercommunalités
dans le domaine je voulais j'étais
d'accord sur le lancement de ce que j'ai
dit
après le débat sur le l'expo universelle
ça c'est autre chose mais est aussi un
point c'est savoir quels liens nous
voulons façonné avec nous habitants
lorsqu'il ya une nouvelle relation a
créé au cours du mandat on a tous essayé
c'est pas du tout une critique ici ou là
on a tous fait la même chose sur des
politiques de de concertation faut aussi
qu'on modernise ce lien et ça sera un
des enjeux de l'élection municipale et
du monde et l'environnement va jouer un
rôle là dedans vous êtes fier de brognon
c'est une commune rurale sûr il ya des
gens qui veulent de l'écologie et il ya
des agriculteurs qui veulent pouvoir
continuer à utiliser du glyphosate
le maire il fait quoi vous êtes devenu
vous êtes écologistes pour la partie
d'habitants qui peut voter pour vous
vous êtes et que les produits fosad pour
les agriculteurs lundi avec
l'association des maires je rencontre la
chambre d'agriculture pour que l'on
réfléchisse au moins à des bons usages à
des relations intelligente de voisinage
ça ça va se faire c'est compliqué c'est
nouveau ça se faisait pas avant
effectivement alors c'était un an qu'on
travaille là dessus il faut avouer quand
même que le contexte mais les chefs de
cette élection c'est nous à pouze non
c'est pas l'élection c'est vraiment lui
contexte actuel nous impose comme
d'accélérer sur ce point là il faut
qu'ils aient un dialogue
après il ya le côté sérieux monaco très
fine du bois du petit lait non méchante
sera vide entre la séléphanto mais par
contre faut arrêter enfin les histoires
de 5,10 m c'est vraiment ridicule et là
il faut vraiment s'appuyer sur les
bonnes pratiques ça va se faire mais ce
que je vous disais on entre vraiment
dans un autre temps de concertation
quand est ce que les gens pourquoi parce
que les gens le veulent
donc est ce que c'est parce qu'il est
prise de conscience parce qu'elle était
bien là les parties notamment en marche
et l air se découvre une passion pour
l'écologie depuis les européennes ce qui
n'est pas le cas enfin quand on regarde
très concrètement il a cédé fait encore
une fois je parlerai dijon parce que je
suis aussi élu à dijon
je veux dire c'est depuis 2001 quand il
ya du bio dans les cantines 30 % de bio
dans les cantines
quand il ya des engagements sur le tram
les mobilités les voies cyclables etc
donc ce sont des faits est là cette
passion la moelle me fait doucement rire
quand je vois le budget la 2020 dans
marche ou le plus grand nombre de postes
la diminution la plus forte baisse de
2,2 le poste d concerne le ministère de
la santé et le ministre la transition
écologique donc d'être brandie soeur de
pancartes c'est une chose de faire c'en
est une autre
nous ont brandi des pancartes et on
faisait les écologistes en dialogue
reprendrait une petite phrase célèbre
allée un peu facile mais les verts n'ont
pas le monopole de l'écologie
vous n'avez pas le monopole de
l'écologie la salle travail 10 mai dans
les discours sans doute dans les actes
pourquoi nicolas hulot à l'émission que
vous n'avez pas le monopole
c'est pas du coeur c'est de l'écologie
bon alors maintenant j'entends ma
collègue ps qui dit on récupère
l'écologie non c'est l'écologie qui nous
récupère ça devient une évidence il ne
s'agit pas des travaux élevé à l'arrêt
ou quoi que ce soit l'écologie fait
partie de notre quotidien maintenant je
prends une génération j'ai des enfants
de 20 30 ans ils sont ni vers ni rien ni
quoi que ce soit ils sont écolo dans
l'âme dans leur quotidien et nous à la
république en marche
on a une écologie du quotidien des
choses très pragmatique
j'ai du quotidien c'est un peu
l'écologie de droite s'annonce l2
pourquoi non mais parce que c'est
l'opposé à l'écologie beaucoup plus oui
il me koubbi cassel une écologie
raisonnable et raisonné quand on est aux
manettes on s'aperçoit de quoi c'est
beaucoup plus difficile qu'on ne croit
on reprend nicolas hulot qui nous avait
rejoints
on peut pas entachée de dire que c'est
pas un écolo 1 il a trouvé
ils pensaient qu'on lui mettait des
bâtons dans les roues mais non ces trois
courses cette saison gagner cette route
il allait il s'est rendu compte qu'elle
était beaucoup plus difficile est
beaucoup plus lente à avancer il ne faut
il ne faut pas encore quand nous
candidats ils veulent être investi il ya
dix engagements y en a un sur la
transition écologique
alors maintenant dans transition
écologique qui à quoi il ya transition
et son il ya quoi transition ça veut
dire un certain temps pour passer d'un
état à un autre
donc les incantations qu'en l'absence y
est très facile mais c'est très curieux
de voir comment
puis le bilan ps écolo bondi elle m'a
parlé de dijon va collègues mais le
bilan rigolo de pièces c'est quand même
voter a fait sourire me suis moqué
l'écologie de droite avec la fuite en
marche vous m'autorisez à me moquer de
la social écologie qui vient
d'apparaître au parti socialiste a
secret parce que c'est vrai parce que
c'est vrai aussi la social-écologie la
nouvelle définition du parti socialiste
c'est très récent aussi ça veut dire que
vous êtes tous en train de tenir compte
des 13 % d'europe écologie aux
européennes 16 en 2009
mais on tient compte on veut faire de ce
sujet qui est si grave qui est grave
parce qu'enfin la catherine tu parlais
du rapport du giec notamment c'est
dramatique donc on veut en faire un
sujet d'étiquette politique de
récupération
je pense qu'il faut dépasser ça et
regarder ce qui se fait donc après
sociale écologique c'était moi je vous
propose de regarder dans les villes je
parle de dijon parce que c'est celle que
je connais le mieux puisque les six
jusqu'à l'exil et dans les cas elles
peuvent être différents mais mais mais
mais regardons ce qui se fait est là et
là c'est pas du citron brandit pas les
pancartes si le fun radio
l'écologie n'est plus donc donc ça qu'on
revient sur notre idée que le bilan des
mères leur travail et leur projet va
peser très lourd dans cette élection
peut-être plus que les politiques
nationales il parti socialiste il se
nourrit aussi de ce qui se fait dans les
territoires parce que contrairement à en
marche il ya on part de ce qui se passe
dans les territoires on écoute on a une
méthode attentive aussi on fait
attention on écoute les gens on écoute
les élus donc on voit bien ce qui ce qui
fonctionne et que la responsabilité que
nous avons sur l'environnement sans sur
l'environnement la responsable et nous
avons sur les défis environnementaux
ça passe par les territoires par des
transformations par des arrêtés anti
anti dufau êtes par exemple les qualifs
la chaleur les choses on est un virage
on est à un tournant
la transition on peut l'imaginer sur 200
ans nous en tant qu'écologistes et pas
dogmatique on dit c'est tout de suite
c'est maintenant parce que on sait les
solutions ans lisa en matière agricole
genre on voit le poids des lobbys qui
existe autour des pesticides de synthèse
à l'échelle mondiale à l'échelle
européenne
sauf que si on s'appuyait sur le
territoire et là pour le coup on en
connaît vous en connaissez peut-être
plus que moi même sur l'ensemble de la
côte d'or c'est les producteurs qui sont
déjà sur des pratiques en bio et qui
alors on s'appuie donc je finis on
s'appuie on s'appuie sur les bonnes
pratiques pour les généraliser pour les
généraliser et on accompagne les
producteurs
après la différence entre les discours
et la question de la crédibilité
concrètes
elle va passer par les budgets
climatique qu'il faut qu'on instaure
dans l'est dans toutes les municipalités
qu'elles soient toutes petites
ils soient des grosses métropoles c'est
ma au moment du budget ce sont des
budgets climatique pas un euro doit
aller à la fuite en avant sur les
énergies dans l'audition dans vos choix
et stratégie ça va rentrer en ligne de
compte
forcément comme dans les petites
communes de côte-d'or il ya deux choses
il ya la commune mais aussi que vous
voulez me dit mon dieu
l'intercommunalité est effectivement il
ya des métropoles encodeur il ya
dix-neuf le péché de l'intercommunalité
chacune a son de gauche de droite
apolitique chacune ont au cours du
mandat essayé de déployer des politiques
environnementales
ça va être un enjeu du prochain mandat
et puis deux joueurs mais mes records et
oecuménique
et puis deuxième chose on toujours dans
cet aspect un peu de rassemblements
il faut que les territoires discutent
entre eux son agressivité ici de
synthèse la république aux marges sont
engagés à les diminuer par deux à
l'horizon 2022 2021 même on peut pas
dire que la république en marche n'a pas
un programme assez ambitieux alors par
des budgets mais personne pour bosser au
ministère de la transition écologique
c'est compliqué d'appliquer ce moment il
ya quand même un ministre qui est
maintenant on aura compris que
l'environnement était va être une
question centrale
il y avait une autre question il reste
cinq minutes on peut se la poser la
question celle des gages isme il ya eu
cette tendance vous avez réagi vivement
tout à l'heure au début d'émission
là-dessus accentuée par le mouvement des
gilets jaunes qui a une forte on va dire
qu'elle exerce une forte pression aussi
sur les élus sur les politiques en
demandant le nouveau comportement
démocratique
est ce que on va diriger il ya eu un
sondage opinionway récents sur ces
municipales dans lequel alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure il ya des signes
très contraire très antagonistes sur
cette élection
71% des sondés disaient vouloir désigner
une personne issue de la société civile
plutôt qu'une personne appartenant à un
parti pour ces élections
est ce que ça vous semble plausible est
ce qu'il ya une volonté de changer ou
parce qu'il irait à l'encontre de ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur les
parties vous voyez ça comment vous sent
très plausible puisque beaucoup
son tissu à la république en marche et
votre serviteur de la société civile
donc c'est quelque chose qui était là
dès end en marche quand ça a été créé
c'était faire appel à société civile
pour renouveler les visages pour
renouveler les comportements et
renouveler les projets donc c'est
quelque chose qui était imposé
l'image que l'on a de la fonction
municipale et la réalité
là je vous répète ce phénomène de
capitation qui va qui se fait dans dans
nos communes
qu'on soit en ville au son d'une petite
commune on n'est pas élu elle est en
marche ps ou verts ont l'air dans les
grandes villes
peut-être l'est dans la grande ville en
est l'exemple prenons l'exemple du maire
on parlait du maire de chalon sur saône
qui porte parole de l'entreprise qu'il
s'engage sur le menu des cantines c'est
extrêmement police n'était tout ce qui
se passe dans les petites communes va
enfin pouvoir se déployer dans des
agglomérations dans des communes
tout à l'heure je vous parlais du
curseur entre le dégagisme légitimisme
le maire et elle et lui préférer
actuellement et la fonction et le corpus
est en train de changer
là en côte d'or on parlait peut parler
de parité
57% des nouveaux maires depuis 2014 sont
des femmes s'est passé quelque chose
la commune est là elle est cette chose
fondamentale mais elle suit aussi
actuellement ce qui se passe dans la
société
oui enfin bon déjà je pense qu'au tour
de cette table bon vous l'avez dit mais
moi je me revendique citoyenne engagée
et pour penser un projet se regrouper
avec un parti politique ça me paraît pas
rédhibitoire et réaffirmé que
l'existence des partis politiques
contribuent à la vie démocratique ça
m'apparaît important de le réaffirmer
par rapport à des postures démagogiques
sur le sur le domaine parce que on peut
faire des déclarations
on va la campagne va agiter beaucoup de
monde mais après une fois l'élection
passée il ya six ans de boulot et saison
de boulot pour le climat pour l'écologie
et pour les solidarités parce que c'est
ça aussi qu'il faut pas oublier que tout
le monde s'y retrouve dans par rapport à
la transition écologique
maintenant je vous les croisez
compétences municipales aussi ajouté oui
tout à fait et buts et politiques ou pas
politique je rebondis je suis assez
cohérentes avec ce jeudi en début
d'émission c'est à dire que le dégagisme
pour moi etc
si c'est mettre dehors des gens qui font
du bon boulot alors des femmes à la
place des hommes parce qu'il a dit à ses
fans au micro casque sommet sera vite eu
cette envie de féminisation grand met en
scène les perdants c'est ce que
catherine hervieu disait moi aussi
j'avoue que je me sens enfin je suis une
citoyenne et je pense qu autour de cette
table on est tous des citoyennes et des
citoyens engagés avec des convictions
très fortes peut-être certains plus que
d'autres et voilà mais on a on a on a un
parcours on a un vécu et et on a une vie
à côté et on a tendance mais aussi à qui
elle profite cette petite musique là de
faire croire que les élus sont une
sphère je pense est désolé jean un peu à
part qu aurait pas de sentiments de
sensations d'émotions qui
s'investiraient pour leur propre il faut
arrêter avec ça vexe et 'le profil avec
sa fille dans le citoyen j'espère que ça
profite aux citoyens à la musique elle
profite elle profite à des partis mais
l'engagement en tout cas et d'être élues
j'espère que ça profite à des citoyens
saprophytes un territoire et plus
largement parce que on fait tous notre
part sur sur cette planète
ça profite à l'humanité et je voudrais
terminer nous reste 20 secondes
confiant qu'il aura pas dégagisme pas de
vote sanction et c'est un peu grâce à la
reine puisque on n'est pas aux manettes
donc ma collègue à dijon peut être
rassuré s'il n'ya pas dégagé de tout sur
elle ça même en 10 secondes démission
quand même être engagée être engagée ça
passe aussi ça peut passer autrement ou
si c'est pas pu en étant élu e alors
nous sommes là il ya le grand déj à
dijon avec la vie associative passerait
un langage ni de 3e temps des
municipales ce sera les sénatoriales et
sera les sénatoriales et aux sectes et
c'est bien sûr en tâche de fond derrière
tout ça merci à tous les autres c'est la
fin de ce débat il faut s'arrêter mais
ça nous dit que les municipales vont
être intéressantes agitée et est fourni
bon dimanche merci merci à tous les
quatre au revoir